It's a new movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, so you know it's full of references
to the comics and movies that have come
before — and maybe the stories to come,
too. These are the Easter eggs you missed in
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings."
Writer/director Destin Daniel Cretton has gone
on record saying "Shang-Chi" is
set after the so-called "Blip,"
when all of the victims of Thanos' snap
have returned after five long years away.
The timeline is established in the movie by
dialogue and the set dressing; take a close
look at the scene early in "Shang-Chi" when Shaun
visits Katy and her family. As he pulls open the
exterior door to her building, you can see a flyer
reading "Post-Blip anxiety? You are not alone."
This might be the kind of sign that advertised
Steve Rogers' support group that he hosted after
the Snap, as seen in "Avengers: Endgame." Of
course, that scene took place before everyone's
return, and Steve ultimately was giving
advice that he may have ended up regretting:
"You gotta move on..."
Yeah, or maybe you have to go back in time
and kick as many asses as it
takes to sort this mess out.
The group advertised in "Shang-Chi" seems to be
not only for those with loved ones who vanished,
but also the people who returned after years
away. At the time when "Shang-Chi" is set,
anxiety is a common affliction. Now that
androids, aliens, and wizards are commonplace,
how can a normal person feel like anything
other than an ant, hoping to not get squashed?
"An ant-man. That's what they called you."
In the mid-credits scene, Shang-Chi and Katy have
a conversation with a virtual Captain Marvel and
Bruce Banner. Along with Doctor Strange
wingman Wong, the braintrust is extremely
interested in the Ten Rings, the tale of how
Shang-Chi acquired them, and their true nature.
They debate the Rings' power and origin, with
Carol Danvers calling them unlike any alien
tech she's ever seen. Eventually, they seem to
conclude that the Rings are some sort of beacon,
sending a message for purposes unknown.
Then Banner signs off by saying:
"Guys, stay safe. Welcome to the circus."
It's a fun cameo scene that seems to set up
our heroes for future Avengers collaborations.
But sharp-eyed viewers might also notice that
Banner's right arm is in a sling. Any guesses why?
As you recall, in "Avengers: Endgame" it
was determined that only the Hulk was strong
enough to wear the Stark Gauntlet and snap
everyone back into existence. But in doing so,
he was exposing himself to massive gamma
radiation, and sure enough, he fried his arm.
In a 2019 interview with ComicBook.com,
"Endgame" director Joe Russo said the
damage is permanent. According to him,
"He's lost an arm ... that's not coming back.
He's damaged himself. It's permanent damage,
the same way there was permanent
damage with Thanos. It's irreversible."
So, will Bruce Banner spend the rest of
his MCU games with his arm in a sling?
In a world where Thor can pop in a new eye and
Rhodey can become paralyzed from a fractured
spinal column but walk again with help from Stark
bionic supports, no injury seems truly permanent.
We'll see how long Ruffalo has to
keep wearing the sling, but in this,
his first Hulk scene since "Endgame,"
it's clear that he's still in a bad way.
Sharp-eyed fans were delighted when, earlier
this summer, they seemed to uncover a quick
shot of Abomination in the "Shang-Chi" trailer.
Sure enough, when our newly-revealed hero makes
his way back to China in an attempt to locate
his sister Xialing, he looks for her at The
Golden Daggers Club and discovers that not only
does she run the place, but currently appearing
on the main stage is a smackdown between
the "Incredible Hulk" villain and Wong.
For starters, there are several things
worth discussing about Emil Blonsky's
monstrous appearance. First, he seems
to be evolving, or, at the very least,
the CGI is getting better — after all, it
has been 13 years since we last saw the guy.
He now has ear fins that look fully
engaged, and he boasts more prominent
dorsal spine needles — both signatures that make
Abomination stand out on the comic book page.
The second interesting thing worth noting
is that the character looks even less
like Tim Roth than he did before
— which is saying something,
because he has never really looked
much like him to begin with.
Over the last decade, Marvel fans have watched
as Hulk has increasingly resembled the actor
who played him, with storylines that sought
to humanize the monster within Bruce Banner.
But while "The Incredible Hulk" gave
us an Abomination whose face at least
somewhat resembled a human's reactions,
the Abomination character design now seems
to be moving in the opposite direction
of Hulk, leaving all humanity behind.
"You have to explain that statement, sir."
"No, I don't."
Perhaps the most notable thing about this
Abomination, however, might be his shift in
tone. As you may recall, after Abomination nearly
defeated Hulk in Harlem, General Thunderbolt Ross
had the creature locked up in a high-tech cell
in Alaska; Phil Coulson said in a 2014 episode
of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D." that he was still in
that cryo-cell. But in the 2011 "One-Shot" short
film "The Consultant," an angry Coulson says the
World Security Council wants Abomination released
and assigned to ... the Avengers initiative?
Coulson says that the Council considers Blonsky
to be a war hero — they want him exonerated,
released, and added to the Avengers roster.
In a conclusion played for laughs, S.H.I.E.L.D.
reveals in the short film that they purposefully
sent Tony Stark to screw up the negotiations —
leading to the "Incredible Hulk" post-credits
cameo where he clashed with a hard-drinking Ross
— and as a result, Blonsky went back into custody.
"Mission accomplished. The Abomination
will remain in his cage for now."
But clearly, Blonsky is not only on the loose
post-Blip, but he seems to be chummy with
Wong — who "Shang-Chi" reveals to be a major
player in the recruitment of new Avengers.
Could it be that (whatever remnants remain of)
the World Security Council finally got their way,
and Abomination will soon be fighting on the
same side as Hulk? Abomination is gearing up
to appear more frequently in the Marvel sandbox,
including the upcoming "She-Hulk" Disney+ series.
"How do you feel?"
"Pissed off and ready for round three."
The first real indication to Shaun
that his reality is about to get very,
very expanded is when he and Katy
are attacked on a San Francisco bus
by several highly-trained men — one of them
wielding a machete in place of his right forearm.
As well-read comic fans will be eager to point
out, his name is Razor Fist, and you wouldn't
want to try and shake his hand. In the comics,
Razor Fist was introduced in 1975 in "Master of
Kung Fu" #29 as a henchman of the evil Carlton
Velcro. This villain had a razor-sharp blade on
each arm — not that it helped him much, as he died
three issues later, shot down by Velcro's guards.
Of course, no comics mantle, however obscure,
is ever laid down for good. Velcro attempted to
create more Razor Fists in 1981 — when brothers
William and Douglas Scott were in a car accident,
he gave them sword arms, too; Douglas died
and William became the new Razor Fist.
In more recent years, that Razor Fist has
appeared in various comics, usually seen
as supporting muscle for supervillains
— much like we find him in "Shang-Chi."
In the background of almost
every scene containing Wenwu,
you may have noticed a silent man dressed
in black, wearing white make-up punctuated
by streaks of red and black. That guy's
name is Death Dealer, and for good reason.
In the comics, the character's real name
is Li Ching-Lin, and like other characters
in Shang-Chi's orbit, he has a history with
MI-6. The baddie was actually a double agent,
working on the sly for Fu Manchu
when he and Shang-Chi had an epic
battle that nearly killed him — and he
then took on the Death Dealer persona.
In "Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings,"
this Death Dealer has clearly been with
Wenwu for multiple decades — and seems to
have largely led the training that taught
Shaun every possible way to kill a man.
The mysterious nature of the live-action
character, coupled with the lack of dialogue,
has given rise to some interesting
theories about Death Dealer,
whose story will certainly be
explored in future movies in the MCU.
Okay, technically this Easter egg isn't in
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings,"
but you'll likely glimpse it in one of
the trailers that plays before the film.
In the multiverse-expanding
first trailer for "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," Dr. Stephen Strange
makes the really, really bad decision
to cast a spell that will make the entire
world forget that Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
Under normal circumstances, an MCU
fan would say: "No way. Wong would
never let such an irresponsible thing
happen. He's the voice of reason."
Great point. But when the cat's away, the mice
will play. So, while we see Wong in the trailer
instructing Strange not to mess with the spell,
we also see him in a winter parka, holding two
suitcases and traveling somewhere that looks like
it has old, regal structures adorned by columns
and domes. Which is when Strange casts his spell
on Peter's behalf, and all hell breaks loose.
Those who've seen "Shang-Chi" know that
Wong pops up multiple times in China,
as well as San Francisco. So, could either of
those be where he's teleporting to in the trailer?
Do the events of that scene run concurrent
to "Shang-Chi"? We'll find out soon enough,
once Spidey's latest adventure
slings itself into theaters.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about "Shang-Chi and
the Legend of the Ten Rings" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.